hello everyone and welcome to bloodline
the taxonomy of fear where we examine
what if anything makes a movie scary and
this week's we're gonna be talking about
exorcism horror with the movie the last
exorcism which picks up immediately
following the events of the first last
exorcism and now we are with our
protagonist Nell Sweetzer she has ended
up in a halfway house for young troubled
girls in New Orleans to sort of pick up
the pieces of her life after the
traumatic events of the first
installment is hear what you're saying
Jordan is that the last exorcism wasn't
really the last exorcism because this is
part 2 exactly that was the penultimate
exorcism and I believe we've now arrived
at the ultimate exorcism that's a bit
awkward yeah all right so what defines
an exorcism horror movie for us jack all
right first and foremost you need
believers people that believe in a faith
that is based on the idea that humanity
hangs in the balance between good and
evil because there cannot be a devil
without a god and devils do not possess
atheists exactly and also it seems like
they don't possess men because the
second criteria is a male identified
demon with a female victim and there's a
lot going on here that we ended up
stumbling upon basically the exorcism
process the possession process is sort
of like just a spiritual rape you have
this male demon invading you know
against the will of the young presumably
female innocent and taking her over and
there's a heightened expression of
sexuality going on there's a loss of
innocence and it all of course has to be
rectified at the end by typically a male
Savior religious figure to come in and
remove that demon from from the victim
which brings us to number three the
exorcism as climax it is the it is what
you work for it is the rocky versus
Drago ending and in this movie it was
they had this was a junior varsity team
of extra oh my god there's no about the
be gay it was like sansas we try to do
in boarding school yeah just covered in
weak sauce it was two inches shy of a
Ouija board exercise
really dissatisfying unfortunately us
but the ending itself was pretty good
yeah I I ultimately was on board with
the resolution of the movie yes so are
you from Colton the woods or something
all right hours of sleep loss Jordan how
did this movie affect you well after we
really dug into the the very close
comparisons between rape and exorcism
and possession it got a lot more
disturbing for me so I'm gonna say about
two hours actually in total I didn't
lose any sleep because i was completely
charmed by Ashley bells performing
absent go from innocent and sweet too
horrified and demonic it was absolutely
mesmerizing she has a career ahead of
her yeah she put this movie on her back
both of them and really did such a good
job at go Ashley Bell yeah all right
horror movie survival lessons Jordan
what did you learn from part dude number
one don't bring a knife to a gunfight
and these exorcist people they brought a
chicken they brought neither it was no
worse performance versus a devil that
you could possibly imagine the kind of
chicken that Berkeley hippies used to
lay their organic exactly this wasn't
even a rooster yes number two by a big
old bag of salt yes I matter what kind
of cell rock salt kosher salt in fact
margaritas might be the best drink to
bring to an XP that's right and once you
have that margarita in hand rule number
three promiscuity is a virtue that's
right we're throwing out the old horror
convention of keep your virginity
because the devil doesn't want to play
around with any sort of impure or
unversed isles so gird yourself from
satanic possession by being a little
fast and loose with your morals I think
I know who to invite to an exorcism
thank you and I'm harga Rita let's go
okay video pic of the week Jay what do
you got for us I'm gonna recommend
Requiem which came out in 2006 from
Germany is based on the true story of a
woman named unleased Mikkel who had
epilepsy but she believed she was
possessed by demons and so did her
family and so they subjected her to 67
exorcisms there is no makeup there's no
special effects there's no projectile
vomiting of split pea soup but
is one of the most effective and moving
and horrifying movies I've ever seen I
highly recommend it as much as I highly
recommend modern medicine I really
appreciate these sort of left of center
recommendation there and I'm gonna go
with something a little more straight up
I'm gonna go with the first movie in
this pair of to the last exorcism
because again Ashley Bell I think she's
worth watching for another movie and it
actually is a very satisfying
found-footage approach to the exorcism
genre that I really could get behind
yeah good movie so that concludes this
week's episode of blood line if you have
any questions comments concerns please
do contact us as always at bloodline at
wired com and as we like to stay here on
the show remember it's just a movie and
exorcism